Someone tell me why there's a three second
teaser for the trailer, right before the trailer.
I mean I already clicked on the video, I'm
clearly going to watch the trailer.
Why are you prolonging it?
Anyways, welcome back to Things You Missed.
This time I'll be looking at the Slenderman
trailer.
It seems like a lot of the suspense will come
from the question of what lies in the abyss?
Is that just a group of skinny trees in the
distance, or is something staring back at
me?
I wanted to analyse these images and find
out, but unfortunately, it seems that there's
only this one sighting as far as I can tell.
It looks like the movie will be centered around
these three girls, which does make me wonder
if they'll incorporate elements of the real
life Slenderman stabbing from 2014, which
was a story about two mentally insane girls
who tried to kill their friend and claimed
that Slenderman made them do it.
We also see this mobile thing, which contains
three girls a bunch of these other figures.
It doesn't look like they'll turn against
each other in this movie, but the idea of
him getting in kids' heads and making them
do stuff seems to be supported by the dialogue:
"He gets in your head, like a virus."
It would seem that this movie is based more
off of that news story than the traditional
creepypasta lore.
The original image from Something Awful forums,
which was the basis for Slenderman as a character
would have been a great easter egg to put
right here, but it looks like they're just
taking it in a different direction with this
one.
The inclusion of these DeviantArt looking
ass Slenderman fangirl hentai drawings instead
is a clear indicator that this film is going
more towards a portrayal of the real world
effect of Slenderman's takeover, rather than
the lore-based one.
Possibly a response to the critical failure
of the Marble Hornets movie.
There also seems to be something about stabbing
out eyes in this movie.
Slenderman has no face so he may be trying
to do the same to his victims.
We see multiple shots of eyes being stabbed
and several pictures on this wall include
eyes and eye injuries.
This character's eyes are different colors,
aaaanndddd I hope you like black licorice.
This looks like a shot out of The Happening..
And when we finally see Slenderman, if you
slow it down, it looks like he could be made
out of the same yarn material as those figures
on the mobile.
You also may or may not have caught this image
of Slenderman in front of a tree flash on
screen for a just a second at the end of the
trailer.
If you were unimpressed with this trailer,
let me know by giving this video a like.
I just wanted to talk about it because Slenderman
is an important part of what made YouTube
horror what it is today.
So if you are interested in creepy stuff online,
then you're gonna wanna go ahead and subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications, buy this
mug, and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.